this is Sal here I'm here with Jeffrey
Rosen head of the National Constitution
Center and we're going to talk about
Article two of the United States
Constitution so Jeffrey what is the
article too deep what is article 2 deal
with it deals with the executive power
the powers of the presidency and it lays
them out and it starts by saying the
executive power shall be vested in a
president of the United States of
America and today that seems somewhat
common sense that the executive power is
vested in the president nighted States
of America why did they have to what
what's special about that
well when the Constitution was drafted
it wasn't obvious that we'd have a
single executive under the Articles of
Confederation all the state governors
had some of them have plural executives
Alexander Hamilton at the Constitutional
Convention was proposing a kind of
monarchy a president for life so the
idea of setting out limited powers for
the presidency and specifying what they
were creating a president that was
energetic enough to achieve common
purposes but restrained enough not to be
a tyrant was a huge achievement to the
Constitution that under the Articles of
Confederation there wasn't a a proper
executive branch it was really the the
president presided so to speak over
Congress that's right and each you you
need a unanimous consent to get anything
done which is why the Confederate
Congress couldn't raise money to support
the war efforts and couldn't raise taxes
so the framers came to Philadelphia to
create a an energetic executive but one
that was also restrained and that's why
the vesting power is so important it
basically says that the all executive
power is vested in the president but
that power is not unlimited now people
have disagreed about how much power the
vesting power grants Theodore Roosevelt
have this stewardship theory that said
the president can be can do anything
that's not forbidden by the Constitution
and article 2 William Howard Taft who
came after Roosevelt had the opposite
theory a kind of judicial theory of the
president he said the president can only
do what isn't forbidden so the question
of whether article 2 is the exclusive
series of presidential powers or whether
there are other implicit powers is a
debate that continues to this day no
this will be fascinated will
we'll go into much more depth in future
videos and just going through the rest
of section one it looks like there's a
lot of the mechanics of what does it
mean to have a term of office what the
how you become president is that
essentially section one you see this
first part he shall hold his office
during the term of four years and
together with a vice president chosen
for the same term be elected as follows
and then they kind of go into the
electoral college system exactly and
then there are a couple of other
requirements no person except a
natural-born citizen can be president
and we know that that term was subject
to some debate during the recent
presidential election and then there's
the provision that says that presidents
have to be 35 years old it's the most
explicit part of the Constitution and
the point was to prevent aristocratic
Saiyans without a lot of experience from
taking office the framers were really
concerned about having new monarchies
and they wanted to make sure that
presidents were seasoned enough so
that's why you can't be President
unless you're 35 fascinating and as we
go further and and I copied this this
text from your website from the National
Constitution Center and why did you all
highlight some of this text of article 2
in this yellow orange color well we're
really thrilled by this website we're
excited to be doing a series of videos
with with you saw and it's the
interactive Constitution folks can find
it at Constitution Center org these are
the main clauses where we commissioned
the top liberal and conservative
scholars to write about what they agreed
and disagreed about these clauses so in
section 1 of article 2 the main clauses
of the vesting clause and that's the one
to focus on the other stuff as you said
it's basically just requirements of what
you have to be in order to be President
and then we highlighted other important
provisions in sections 2 3 and 4 yeah
and in particular this section on the
electoral college system this was
superseded I saw I learned from your
website by the 12th amendment that
because of what happened with with with
Aaron Burr and Thomas Jefferson yes we
know that from a musical Hamilton that
the election of 1800 did not end well it
was actually a tie in the house and so
it went into the electoral college and
and rather a tie in the electoral
college it went to the house and
Alexander Hamilton cast his support for
Jefferson over Burr and burr was so
furious about that that he challenged
Hamilton to the duel that I ultimately
killed him but the peculiarity of having
the original system where the first
place winner in the electoral college
became president and the second place
winner became vice president was so
unwieldy that that provision of the
Constitution was amended and now as we
know Presidents and vice presidents run
on a single ticket yeah yeah and then
the rest of section 1 it kind of
finishes off with in the case of the
removal of the president is death
resignation and ability to discharge the
power so this is it talks about how
Congress can provide for who should be
President next exactly so and there are
statutes that provide that and Congress
has an elaborate rule of secession that
it's created as empowered by this part
of the Constitution yeah and then the
last two pieces here it talks about just
the compensation of the president cannot
be increased or diminished during the
the period for which he shall be elected
maybe to prevent him from giving himself
a raise or herself from giving herself a
raise and then the last is just the the
famous oath of office I do solemnly
swear or affirm that I will faithfully
execute the Office of the President of
the United States and will do to the
best of my ability preserve protect and
defend the Constitution of the United
States
Sall you did a great job although there
was an extra do in there and I'm
pointing that out because remember when
Chief Justice Roberts administered the
oath to President Obama the fact that he
slightly bungled it led Roberts just to
be safe to re administer the oath so I
think you saw if you want I can do it
again and maybe you'll be President
sounds good salad sounds good so then we
get into section 2 which is I think
maybe it gets a little bit more involved
this this first this first paragraph
here it says the President shall be the
commander in chief of the Army and Navy
of the United States and clearly they
don't say all of the different forces of
the United cuz we didn't have an Air
Force then yeah or or Marines we
sure didn't but there was a concern
about the king of controlling the
military so the two main purposes of
this commander-in-chief clause are first
total civilian control of the military
and second the idea that there's just a
single leader so the military is
subordinate to civilian and
democratically accountable control and
unlike the Articles of Confederation a
single person gets to control all of
this power so that you can have
coordinated military force and as simple
and as clean as this statement seems to
be in future videos we'll discuss more
of how this may or may not be in
contention with the power given to
Congress in article 1 around the right
to declare war exactly right we know
that the president in section 2 has the
power to Congress has the power to
declare war and the question of what the
president can do is contested as you
said we'll talk about it more later but
everyone agrees that the president has
the ability to repel sudden attacks at
the same time we haven't had a declared
war since World War two although there
have been lots of military actions and
the question of how much independent
power the president has to initiate
military action is very hotly contested
yeah and then this next section this
talks about the power of the President
to make treaties but what's the advice
and consent of the Senate and it has to
be approved provided two-thirds of the
Senators present concur yes
so the treaty power shared between the
president and the Senate and generally
people think that the Senate can approve
or disapprove or maybe attach conditions
or reservations to the treaty but the
president alone has the power to
negotiate treaties and that was a
precedent set by George Washington so
the treaty power is shared and there's a
lot here because it also talks about the
power of the President to appoint
ambassadors other public ministers
consuls judges of the Supreme Court and
other officers the United States so this
is pretty important sentence there it
sure is we know now
from controversy over Supreme Court
nominations that the so called advice
and consent Clause is really important
the advice and consent Clause is limited
to high officers as opposed to inferior
officers because the clause says for
inferior officers Congress convened and
the president alone in the courts of law
are the heads of the department but for
high-ranking officials like Supreme
Court judges the president can nominate
the Senate exercises advice and consent
and this is a shared power between the
president Congress yes and and and just
to make people familiar with the
language when they're talking about
inferior officers they're not making any
judgment about those people's capability
it's more they're talking about a more
junior less less senior officials in the
government that's an excellent point
but although it is a term of art it's
hugely important and people have
disputed about who counts as an inferior
officer because a lot hangs on if the
officer is inferior then the president
alone doesn't get to appoint them and
there's and then they sorry I know I
know also the question of who the
president can remove or fire without
congressional approval is important and
may hinge on that question as well right
and we'll talk more about it but it
seems like the you need Senate consent
for more of the getting people into
their their jobs but being able to
remove them as often times there's more
power there for the president absolutely
although again like most of these powers
they're contested their arguments on
both sides throughout history and the
Supreme Court has both recognized the
president's unitary authority to fire
executive branch officials but in other
cases has said that Congress can impose
certain conditions on when the president
could fire someone at someone we'll talk
about it more but this this next
sentence really is is also really
interesting one is that look when the
when the Senate is in recess the power
shall have the president the President
shall have the power to fill up all
vacancies and it seems like it's a
temporary filling of positions by
granting Commission's which shall expire
at the end of their next session that's
exactly right and the president's power
to make recess appointments was just
litigated before the Supreme Court and
the Supreme Court unanimously said that
President Obama could not make certain
appointments because
wasn't technically out of session so the
question of when the Senate is in recess
is very contested and the scope of that
power is really important as well yeah
and section three is it kind of just
says hey the president can get Congress
together for the state of the union can
address Konig risk and kind of tell
Congress what's on it with on his or her
mind all right yes it does say that and
the state of the union power is really
important you know there's one other
clause in Section 2 that we just want
might want to flag and that's the take
care Clause sorry that's in section 3
and I know you're about to get to it so
so we start with this ability to give
Congress information about the State of
the Union the ability to convene both
houses of Congress in cases of
disagreement among them but then you get
to this really core power that he shall
take care that the laws be faithfully
executed and why is that so important
that he takes care of the laws I mean
isn't that what the executive should
should be doing absolutely but there is
a serious question what happens if the
President believes a law is
unconstitutional then is it the kind of
law that he has to execute and President
Thomas Jefferson said no he refused to
enforce the Sedition Acts which
basically allowed the government to
punish people who criticize the
president on the grounds that Jefferson
believed that it was unconstitutional
more recently we've had a big
controversy over this clause when
opponents of President Obama's executive
orders about immigration have said that
they're a violation of his power to take
care that the laws are faithfully
executed because according to opponents
Congress reached a different immigration
policy the Supreme Court ultimately
refused to cleanly decide that because
of the four-four split and we didn't
clearly rule on the question of the take
care Clause in the immigration policy
fascinating and just to finish up here
and we'll go deeper in future videos as
we go into section four this really just
talks about how the President or the
Vice President and all civil officers
and I states how they might be removed
from office that's right and we know
from not
so distant history that the only way
that the president can be removed from
office is by impeachment of president is
impeached by the house and has to be
convicted by the Senate two presidents
have been impeached in American history
Andrew Johnson and Bill Clinton neither
has been convicted so we've never
actually had a president who's been
removed from office through the
impeachment clause and a lot of times in
popular language impeachment to be clear
impeachment is the accusation and then
you have to be held that no you actually
did commit those crimes happen and
that's what you're saying that the
Senate is responsible for that's right
you can be an impeached but acquitted
and that's what happened to both Bill
Clinton and Andrew Johnson so it's like
being indicted but then you go to trial
and you're later acquitted you get to
keep your office well thanks so much
Jeffrey this is this is a super valuable
overview thanks it's been great to talk